all right becky
becky where'd you grow up where are you
from originally i'm from albuquerque new
mexico i'm becky um
i was born in albuquerque and i grew up
in
uh colorado arizona and l.a tell me
about your family
my family is
orphan their orphan and they grew up and
they made up they met each other my mom
and dad met each other both orphans and
like sometimes l.a or somewhere
i eat come on east coast west coast and
they came together somewhere and they
made a family and
didn't work out and it's my um
i don't know we kind of separated i
stayed with my dad and other kids
separated and i
i went and did
something good i went to college and
i struggled with drugs alcohol and
alcohol and i want to get sober and
i like [ __ ] i like to work in church and
help
like
serve like water or whatever and
wash hands tell me about your your
childhood again my childhood i had
mental ill mental illness and abuse i
was um because what kind of abuse um my
parents were orphaned when growing up
there they didn't know how to be parents
and they abused and they used drugs and
they were abusive what kind of abuse
were you going through a physical invert
like but like just
um just like
yelling screaming
but not sexual
uh no not really no
and so drug use started for you when
it started with my parents
no but when did it start for you um
alcohol was like young it was like
before i was 10 but drugs didn't start
until
i think i started doing drugs until i
was
15 16 that almost almost around 18.
what drugs were there um just something
that was available when i started like
finding out about like sex and money and
going places and doing
that making bad choices
like we uh uh here we'd crystal bass and
crack go crack cocaine i didn't really
start doing until i came here enjoy
and i don't know how until i kind of got
i don't know it was something
weird how long have you been down here
at skid row
it was something like racism was a
racist fight food fights that's what it
was
that's when i started using crack
cocaine it was only started here kind of
i skipping brawl since 2009
uh 15 years
no um
11 11 years okay
yeah i've been here
i got an apartment and i went to college
vocational i made a lot of friends made
a lot of bad choices i run around in the
street at night and i straight bent like
the [ __ ] be a good [ __ ] and [ __ ] and
suck and
whatever money get money do it right and
sometimes i get ugly and i get i get
beat up or
i get robbed or i get loud i get
lynched out of cars
it's cold out because you know
as long as you know that you know
you can process something that happens
keep going
and go and help so go be with somebody
and act normal
and do it again yeah it's not gonna be
the same how much money were you making
tonight uh
a hundred dollars is cool you know right
for yeah like if i'm out there just like
if i'm really doing it if i'm not just
like [ __ ] half or sleep or something
a hundred dollars
yeah no not at one time just different
like all dolls like two or three two or
three dates but if i'm like half asleep
sometimes i'm like half asleep
because i need help and everybody needs
that help what is your drug now
um
i smoke cigarettes and i
sometimes i drink um
i can't really smoke that much anymore
because i don't eat a lot
i don't really have a home i try to
smoke sometimes
i'm trying to get back into it but it's
kind of social
there's going to be a food fight
somewhere and i can't get involved in it
it's not real it's not it's not normal
for me to be using what to do with
everybody do you have kids rebecca yeah
i have two kids
and they they're with the there they got
taken i'm not allowed to talk about them
no more the court they made weird
paperwork
i like this place this is fun this is
cool here it made my life i was born
and the last baby in my family and they
had something they were gonna do with me
my parents and this is a weird story but
i don't really talk about it with
anybody here but that's how i got
involved in skid row it was something
like my my parents were trying to like
do something like with like sacrifice me
or something they went to the wrong guy
was that fifth street and weird thing is
he still kind of you know about it but
if you go to the right most of them they
will right they'll take any kid even me
but they went to the right wrong one and
he kept me alive so that's my schedule
made me gave me extension and gave me a
good life
you get this is good i like being a part
of this mark this is nice hi becky
yeah
becky what to hallelujah hallelujah
you've had bad things happen to you out
here yeah a lot of bad a lot of good and
i want i don't want to just stay
with
everyone that can't that can
i can do what i can do
but what kind of things have happened to
you
working at the street oh just like
get thrown out of cars or just kind of
robbed or beat up or um
clothes taken away maybe
get going to a party i didn't know i'm
going to party
right
it's things like that like oh my god
we're going to party i thought i thought
we know we're going to party and i'm
going to leave right here with no
clothes nothing
yeah
things like that happen and it shouldn't
happen you just process it one time
angry and sad and just like no one wants
to hear about it
not bringing anything not doing anything
for everybody and and like all of us
together like you know where do you stay
at night uh or i mean you're like an
apartment i paid for our friends there
that take me on like like a family
um
i have a chat there's a few chants
around l.a that take me in if i really
need it but i don't i
older as i get older i need like four
hours of sleep a day and i can get it
during the day
when you get real old you know you start
getting older typically you're up all
night yeah i'm up all night but i get
enough sleep like during the day right
right there's nothing
i'm little i'm white i don't need a
whole lot of sleep there's not a lot i
have to do if i don't get like messed up
it'll get beat up that much i eat you
ever talk with your family still
uh yeah once i talked one time this year
i don't know the other people in the
family like i said when i was a teenager
we all separated i don't know if there's
a real name that was an identity person
that with the name
so i just kind of leave those those
it's just my dad and whatever my dad
says is part of the family i don't know
because whatever like sibling
or parent uh my mom whatever i don't
know if that's the right person going
with the name
because it's been a long time
after i was like 14
13
i never really seen them again
so i kind of just left that alone they
didn't really want to be
with me they never wanted to do what i
do and they kind of just
were mean and miserable and it's like
they already
did the didn't did themself in
like it was almost like they kind of
just like [ __ ] up already and like it
was time for them to go
sometimes girls are like that i didn't
know that's what it was when i was
growing up but now i think about yeah
sometimes that happens to little girls
you know
i i had family members like they're all
girls i had sisters
i don't i don't really i don't know
because sometimes that did happen i
didn't see him ever again
sometimes they get they do something bad
and that's it
over life over that's how it used to be
in in the 80s 90s right
accidents
never see him again until the government
replaces them with somebody new
right
i like that and they do that here the
government does it here and i like it i
still want to do that
but all in my lifetime
becky what are you afraid of what do you
worry about
uh i'm afraid of all in my all uh all my
i'll end my life
in a time
that i'm using drugs and hoeing
right i'm right now and i faced my fear
i faced my fear with that you know
all i'm going to get from that is
carried somewhere and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
in the ass
right what kind of sexual favors will
you do
i i like to suck jack i just like you
know oral style socks and i like to just
i kept like comparing old men they like
to hang out old men like hang out with
me
right
and just be there
make them feel good
right yeah you have to do a lot just be
just be there with them that's nice i
like them just a companion i just like
them something new other than that
whatever got taken
you know you'll have
you'll have what kind of sex with people
when you're doing that i just get naked
a lot of touch on me and then i'm just
like alone and just tell me what you
want me to do i just kind of like
move around and just i don't know i
tried i want i want to just be how i try
to just be happy with them and just get
sexual do something sexual do you get
guys asking you to do it without a
condom yeah it happens a lot and i was
uh from when i just you know i was on
the sidewalk that's a food fight
a condom
i said i'm not ready for that so all i'd
say is no i don't have anything and now
i use them and then call if you want to
give it to me for money first all right
we could go we could do it right here
i i don't i don't know because it's like
it's like animal planet here sometimes
you get uh depressed or angry or
anxious or anything like that sometimes
yeah i get sad and i get angry
because i get sad because
oh what was it um
i get sad because i want what i can't
have
you know
this is what i have and i don't want it
but this is what i have here what would
you like to see happen in your life what
do you want i want everybody everybody
in the gum and i'm all the program and
all that but all the things i'm supposed
to get you know the papers all the
things that the government said they're
gonna give everybody i want that all
done given
right
and just like things like that just
things that were promised everybody are
just like angry because law one
i have to do something about anything
that gets taken already i already they
say i already had didn't have whatever
but
it's yeah i get sad about like just not
having friends and the same thing
are you lonely
yeah i get no not really not lonely no
i'm just
i it's anger sad angry sad back and
forth
because if even if it wasn't me
it doesn't matter somebody already got
it used it up and then the program can't
they cancelled out the programming
all right okay
i believe that's cool have you been
alive before in your life love yeah i
did i like a lot love is cool it's a it
lasts a few days maybe a year a couple
years right
and it's
good uh no
court ordered
you know marriage is different like
based on you know
involvement are you married
no no
how old are you
31
did you have dreams of doing something
different with your life when you were
younger
no my dreams was kind of weird my dreams
involved something like
i don't know
it involves my body when my body parts
get collected and randomly scattered
throughout america
my dreams involve that right yeah i hear
how i see it sometimes
you have interesting dreams yeah and i
really don't you know we have we i still
have a problem with the people when i
see him again
he says how are you going to collect
body parts and you're going to come
around me again and act like it wasn't
me
act like it wasn't the same it's the
same one it's the same body yet we all
have the same same thing that you took
but what i meant with my question was
the kardashians right yeah nobody used
to collect body parts all the whites
yeah i was trying to ask you if you had
goals of oh yeah those are part of my
goals yeah i i like to have to have a
better experience
just like you know include jesus a
little more more
nice to be nice to each other honest and
do everything we're gonna do
becky do you have any regrets in your
life no
i'm cool with everything i don't want i
don't like a red cross it didn't take
long to answer that one no because it's
a lot to me i don't i lose in my brain
i can't understand it after if i do if i
have a regret and act on it i'm not
gonna understand why what that was
you know i tried to make it really
simple
becky have you learned anything in your
years
30 years here yeah i learned something
and free my mind because the piper top
part of my head's gonna be hot dog
and if i choose to go with the black
girls it's just gonna be hamburger
so
i don't know it's just i try to just try
to be okay everywhere where i'm at
whatever happens in the food fight
food fight one
that's what i learned food fight one
what is a food fight a food fight is
whoever wants it whoever wants it bad
enough
to do something about it long enough
even in the bible it's weird
this food food fight over something like
dogs clothes bathrooms thousand rights
shoes
yeah you know it's scary [ __ ] too
you're my top won't have anything to do
with my feet or my head has nothing to
do with it waiting to fight
i don't know
all right thank you thank you so much
for thank you
yeah
i wish you the best i want to be a
priest i wanted to be to praise somebody
in church i know i i always remember
that i wanted to work in the church
you guys say hey can berry right i look
all evil and sometimes i look really
evil and me
yeah you don't or sometimes
it's like it could bury it could very
trait right
it's like what do i have to do where do
i have to go
lay down make it snowing all the grounds
you know things i'm like
corolla
right okay
all right thank you thank you very much
that is cool
stop it
oh
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
hi i'm sorry hey rebecca how are you
doing i'm not sure i'm trying to pull my
pants off it won't stop doing this [ __ ]
to me
oh
ah
you